notre invité wilfried font qu'il est
sobre international du fap unsa
bonsoir à vous il fait front commercial
être avec nous en direct sur rt france
concrètement qu'est ce que ce recours
judiciaires change pour le personnel
pénitentiaire parce que jusqu à présent
qu est-ce qui était justement fait
lorsqu'un détenu s'estimer victime de
conditions
là un de détention indignes
écoutez ça va changer pour les
personnels c'est simplement leur ajouter
une difficulté supplémentaire dans
l'exercice de leur mission parce que
quelqu'un très concrètement aujourd'hui
un détenu a effectivement va pouvoir
faire un recours sur ses conditions de
détention mais derrière sur le terrain
quelle réponse on va être en mesure de
lui apporter et bien je peux vous la
donner dès aujourd'hui en fait on en a
aucune c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de
solution aujourd'hui à apporter un
détenu qui va faire un recours sur ses
conditions de détention et au delà de ça
ce qu'il faut aussi avoir en tête c'est
que ces fameuses conditions de détention
ont lesquelles les détenus sont
autorisés aujourd'hui à faire des
recours sont des conditions de travail
des personnels et eux n'ont ni cette
capacité de faire un recours et encore
moins le droit d'aller faire grève ou de
manifester pour demander une
amélioration de leurs conditions
donc quelque part on est en train de
créer du droit pour la population pénale
c'est très bien mais quelque part c'est
une manière pour les décideurs
politiques d'aller se cacher une fois de
plus derrière leur petit doigt et
d'éviter d'aller affronter le problème
qui sont au-delà des conditions de
détention la manière dont aujourd'hui on
prend en charge la population pénale
pour avoir un véritable impact
quant à leur éventuelle réinsertion mais
aussi derrière en matière de sécurité et
sécurité publique pour assurer nos deux
missions qui sont la garde à la
réinsertion ce qui a été fait je reviens
à ma question aussi qu'est ce qui était
fait lorsqu'un auparavant lorsqu'un
détenu justement s'estimer victime de
conditions indignes de détention
lui faire trop grand chose parce que les
des établissements pénitentiaires sont
aujourd'hui dans l'état dans lequel ici
malgré l'investissement on va dire les
choses est vraiment un investissement
qui est fait à la fois pour la
maintenance du partage actuel mais aussi
la construction de nouveaux
établissements mais quelque part hormis
de changer de cellule et elle est maître
dans une cellule dans laquelle on va
remettre un coup de peinture ou
éventuellement aller le transférer vers
une autre structure qui sera peut-être
un peu mieux en matière immobilière mais
au-delà de ça on n'a aucun pouvoir faire
plusieurs fois et est condamnée pour
l'état de ses prisons vous avez vous
même été témoin de certaines conditions
dégradantes ce qu'on pouvait nous en
parler
ou dissoudre et gras dont il faudrait
déjà qu'on se mette d'accord sur le
thème conditions dégradantes parce que
on peut aussi se poser la question de
savoir si finalement
le personnel de surveillance notamment
qui est confrontée aux violences au
dessus rachat aux jets d'uriné roger
d'extrêmement est ce que ce ne seront
pas aussi des conditions dégradantes de
l'exercice de leurs missions quand on
parle de conditions dégradantes aussi
remettre les choses
dans le bon sens derrière personne devra
demander une onu à la population pénale
de jeter leurs détritus ou les repas qui
leur convienne mois par les fenêtre de
leur cellule donc il ya aussi quelque
part un peu avoir échangé et qu'il faut
faire un peu la part des choses et se
dire que finalement les conditions
d'incarcération en france sont peut-être
nettement meilleure aujourd'hui que
c'est qu'on peut trouver dans d'autres
pays dans le monde donc soyons un petit
peu raisonnable mais si là dessus on
travers le recours judiciaire qui entre
en vigueur aujourd'hui ne va pas aider à
lui seul le problème de la densité
carcérale qui est de 117 % qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire et ce qu'il faut
construire plus de prisons
ont sur plus de prisons certainement oui
parce que aujourd'hui il a une évidence
c'est que cruellement place notamment
dans les maisons d'arrêt parce que la
surpopulation pénale aujourd'hui ce sont
les maisons d'arrêt c'est à dire les
établissements dans lesquels on
accueille des personnes d qui sont en
attente de jugement donc les délais
aussi de justice quelque part nous
contribue également à cette
surpopulation pénale donc je pense que
c'est une réflexion beaucoup plus
globale à la fois sur une politique
carcérale moderne pour pouvoir justement
moderniser l'administration
pénitentiaire la rénover la rend
beaucoup plus sûres mais c'est aussi une
réflexion globale sur la justice pénale
en france pour savoir aujourd'hui quel
est le sens de la peine comment on fait
de finalement en le temps de
l'incarcération on en fait un temps
utile à la fois pour le détenu à la fois
pour les victimes mais aussi plus
globalement à la fois pour pour la
société donc c'est un véritable
véritable réflexion qu'il faut mener
donc il ya des états généraux de la
justice qui vont avoir lieu dans pas
longtemps est-ce qu'on va aborder le
sujet on l'espère mais à chaque fois le
sujet de la prison de finalement c'est
pas un sujet glamour donc nos décideurs
politiques généralement il évite un peu
le sujet parce qu'on n'est pas une
priorité budgétaire on le voit encore
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que quelque
part on est une priorité budgétaire pour
la population pénale pour laquelle
l'avocat ministre des détenus réussi à
débloquer 50 millions d'euros quand il
s'agit des personnels et mama fond nous
donne au départ 2 millions puis après 4
donc bon ma foi yahia il ya aussi pour
faire la part des choses là dedans alors
la densité car ça peut-être que ce sera
l'objet de débats alors al'approche
justement de l'échéance de la
présidentielle qui approche merci à vous
et wilfrid fond sur internationale usap
unsa